with permission from their parents CBS
Evening News anchor Jeff Glor spoke with
four students who survived the shooting
they talked about what they witnessed
and how they will remember and heroic
coach and finding strength in each other
we realize it was an active shooter and
information just started pouring in
about kids being shot and one of my best
friends was in the building and she
wasn't answering and I just didn't know
if any of them were okay I saw confusion
and panic in the faces of people that I
went to school with played rec sports
with and saw every single day of my life
for the last four years
everyone would never think that this
would happen to a school but things are
possible
I could harm anyone how many of you lost
friends yesterday and lost family every
single person in that building that was
Tasha's just
that shouldn't happen how many of you
knew coach face he was different than
normal faculty he was our friend he
truly cared I don't think I have a
single negative memory of him and every
single time I saw him it was just a
feeling of I wish I could do more I wish
I said more I wish I told him how much
he meant to us coach vice standing in
front of a shooter or a rifle and taking
shots he would do anything for us and
that proved that I just wish that he
didn't have to do that to prove it I
lost quite a few friends yesterday one
that I had cost booth it was very close
to me and knowing that they're gone and
I would argue with them that one person
that I had class would that had
arguments with him and never being able
to say I'm sorry and that I care about
him it kills me inside Chuck you um you
knew Nick since sixth grade these be
always been around I used to always hear
stories about him throwing rocks through
windows pulling the fire alarm for fun
no one was really too close to him
because it was always assumed that if
this were to happen it'd be him someone
having the ability to instill that much
terror in the people I love hurts nobody
should have to go
do this ever like my my mom's best
friend was waiting was waiting all night
because she couldn't find her son and
then now he's no longer with us and I
think that this could have been
prevented he should have never been able
to get a gun you think you'll feel safe
when you go back I believe that Stoneman
Douglas is still a very safe school
because we are a huge family and through
this whole ordeal we will be brave and
fight where Eagles we're not puppies
it's not gonna be easy Ariana if we all
see each other again we might feel more
at home I am so impressed by all of you
from the strength that you're showing
right now it's not that we have to do
this for ourselves you have to do this
for those who can't because there's
plenty of people right now who have
things to say who have things just to be
here for but they can't bring themselves
to do it and we have to be here for them
until they're ready as painful as it is
I'm really glad they're speaking out
because I think it makes a difference
when you get to see the people behind
this behind this horrible tragedy the
victims range in age from 14 to 49 also
very very young you're gonna live with
this for the rest of their lives that's
right this has had such a deep impact on
them and to hear them witness also to
the kinds of people like coach Feist
what they were like beforehand the kind
of people they were the kind of lives
you live that now those lives even
though they're gone gives strength to
those people who work who are having to
carry on it and they still got to have a
tough time you know it was hard for me
to hear the gunshots and we're sitting
in the comfort of our home I can't
imagine what it was like for them to be
there and know every time you're a gun
shot possibly somebody is dying it's
it's horrific